could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
people know jackmate for
being the guy to slag stuff off and
that's funny and then when the content
dried up well i've now gotta go and look
for someone who's doing something wrong
you can only do that for so long before
you just hate yourself
didn't really get on with my mum she
would do and say things that i don't
think any mum should really do things
would happen at home
and i'd have like a mark on my face like
from someone that shouldn't have given
me that mark i made a video reacting so
well as advent calendar that changed the
game for me and that the upload before
that i was gonna quit i struggle with um
health anxiety and ocd there's probably
15
to 20 times a day where i actually
convince myself that i have cancer so
you're too fearful to go and get a
health check done if i go there
and the doctor's like yeah you're ill
then that's the end for me what do you
mean that's the end for you
[Music]
jack give me the uh give me the context
on your life you know i sat here
yesterday with the israelites anya and
he told me about his childhood um and
there was hints of that that really kind
of
felt similar to the experience that i
read you've had as a young man as well
and then also i think the other one
where i could see real distinct
similarities and i think you might
listen to this podcast is jimmy carr
yeah yeah what man yeah what a man right
he's like i didn't realize he was he was
gonna be such a philosopher one of the
things he said to me was you know when
someone becomes a comedic figure which i
consider you to be in many respects i
think you like that yeah okay um he he
says that instead of asking
because there's you know there's this
kind of stereotype that the person
themselves is struggling with something
and they're trying to make other people
laugh he said to me as you might have
heard he said you've actually got to ask
them which one of their parents they
were trying to please or to to make
happy does that resonate with you at all
um
yeah i mean upbringing
didn't really get on with my mum i don't
think she truly understood the potential
in youtube whereas my dad always did so
when i was sort of like
like
i guess how old are you steve 29 29 okay
so i'm 29 in like two weeks time so we
were kind of like
the first kind of content creators in a
way like we we kind of like paved the
way if you will some people just i was
late to the party well people like
charlie are so cool i did i just
followed them i guess but um yeah my mum
didn't really get
she might she might argue this point i
don't know but i don't think she really
saw the um
the potential in what i was doing so i
was just some kid in my bedroom just
talking to a camera just waffling not
getting a real job sort of thing and um
she has she has her issues and stuff
with alcohol and whatnot ended up
kicking me out long story short um
i was kind of at a crossroads at some
point quite early on maybe like 1819
where i was living in my uncle's
box room at his at his um flat which
isn't the nicest environment in the
world i think you wouldn't mind me
saying
and then i kind of thought
okay i have to try and take this youtube
[ __ ] serious and at that time i didn't
know what the youtube [ __ ] was so ever
since that moment i think the pivotal
moment for me was i bought a whiteboard
i bought a whiteboard and that changed
that yeah that changed everything and
because i never took youtube serious
like a job like a nine to five it was
always something that i would just
just do just just moan about something
or take it
do a funny take on something or whatever
so i bought a whiteboard chopped it up
into a month and wrote my plan and then
i think it was in like 2012
i had this thing where i was like i'm
just going to say yes to anything that
comes in my inbox and i just for 365
days just did and then ever since then
it's just felt like i'm on this weird
kind of
like i've still not worked it out like
you've got your [ __ ] together steve no i
haven't
no idea look how many cameras
yeah an indication of having my [ __ ]
together but i okay you're a dragon eyes
mad isn't it yeah yeah just the word
dragon like that's mental it is crazy
you've just reminded me of how much i
resonated with what you were saying
because i had a really
um what's the right word
i had a a real issue with the fact that
my mother was so different
right and so
challenging at times like as i write
about my book showing up to my school in
her lingerie when i was maybe
seven years old yeah and things like
that right
and i've always
really wanted to have a normal family
and a normal
mother yeah that kind of thing and i
kind of i kind of got that from reading
your stuff and there's a couple of
things where you talk about some of the
challenges you think she has
which i also think my mother has oh wow
really she's actually
started to talk a little bit about that
yeah
yeah
sorry yeah i don't know if my mum's ever
been diagnosed with it um because
there's always been kind of like rumors
and that that that's the case and i've
cause i've not been a part of her life
in the past like eight nine years i
don't know oh you haven't no not re i
see her at like my nans at christmas
time and stuff but there's always a very
awkward kind of
vibe where now it's kind of just like
like nodding terms and
for someone who's your mum that's a
weird that's a weird thing to be yeah
it's just it's just yeah growing up it's
just you hit the nail on the head there
when you said about your mum like she
would do and say things i don't think
any mum should really do and it's hard
now because at what point do you
at what point is it
water under the bridge like at what
point do you go okay i'm just gonna make
up with her sounds very like juvenile
and stuff but when so much has happened
in your past how
when is the day when you go okay i'll
accept you again now and she sees that
cause she'll text me every now and then
but my worry is that because she's
always struggled with
alcoholism
she'll text me at half 11 on a saturday
night i want to get that text message at
10 30 on a tuesday morning i don't want
to get it at 11 30 on a saturday night
so i won't reply and then she'll just
assume that there's a lot of animosity
still there and i guess there is but
yeah it's funny because i sat here
actually i think yesterday with my
sister and i don't see my sister much i
think i see my sister once a year right
and my sister really wants me to kind of
like reconnect with my mum and like get
back on good terms with her but um for
the exact i think that sounds like
pretty similar reasons to you i was
trying to explain to my sister that like
i need to have boundaries with everybody
in my life not just like
my friends but also with my family and
at some point you've got to protect
yourself yeah from going back around the
[ __ ]
yeah you know like taking them back in
forgiving them for whatever they might
have done for you done to you and then
getting sucked back in because you know
you're
you've fallen for this trick once almost
yeah oh mate i've fallen for it too many
times yeah and and i really got my life
together and i started on this kind of
trajectory where i am now once i left
home that was when it was kind of like
okay you need to make this work or you
you're just done you're just in your
uncle's box room forever sort of thing
so if it weren't for my mum i would have
bought that whiteboard yeah what a
pivotal moment yeah what about your dad
i heard that story about watching the
world cup and that was
yeah my dad's quality my dad is quality
because he's been through a lot of stuff
in his life so i don't know if you know
but my dad went to prison for
manslaughter when he was
young very young um yeah i got got in a
fight with um
with with some some bloke outside a pub
got in a in a dispute and uh hit him and
the guy fell and and passed away
and that plagues my dads now because
they're just two kids fighting in a in a
pub car park like so he went to prison
he came out and he's just he's just a
grafter like that pains him inside he
has to live every day with that
obviously it's not right we did but um
i'm never i'm never going to say that
but he's brought me up with a lot of
morals and he's taught me if you ever
get in any fights like you run away like
you don't need to be the big man like
like he was and he's always had my back
from day one and he's like my best mate
so
for example like
when i first got my my first youtube
check through i think it was like 60 was
like the threshold that you had to get
back in the day and i think i got paid
so it was at 45 quid or something and um
i'm from i'm from a council estate never
had any money and i got that 45 pounds
and instead of giving my mom any money i
just went to top man bought some
t-shirts you remember them old sort of
t-shirts for the
yes with the little buttons down here oh
my god i wanted every color yeah the
color was different color to the top
yeah and the buttons were different
colors yeah and i got a couple of those
and um i was i was in my room and i
remember my mum coming in and having a
go and being like oh you should give me
like half of that or whatever and then
she went and you've just wasted on
[ __ ] t-shirts and i had done that
that is literally what i bought but my
dad i remember my dad coming in and
going he needs those t-shirts because he
can't be wearing the same stuff in all
of his videos
it was like he didn't know if that was
why i was buying them or not but like
he'd literally just made up a reason to
apply it to my youtube channel and
justified why i was like why did i have
to justify that age why i'm buying
t-shirts but my dad just knew from the
off i i guess none of us really knew the
potential in youtube back in the day we
were all just sort of
testing the waters and just having fun
but i feel like my dad kind of had an
idea that i'm he he he trusted that i
saw something in it even if he didn't so
i owe him a lot in that respect and now
when i see him if i've been doing good
in my life bad in my life if i've
yeah i'll tell him everything and he'll
just give me the best advice ever and
yeah it's just i'm glad i had him
because he was very much the
the counterweight i really vividly
remember the moment when my dad called
me to the kitchen table and basically
said i don't know i don't have your
mother
right like i can almost
remember what i was wearing and i
remember from reading about your story
that there was a moment where your dad
basically said i'm gonna leave after
this football match yeah yeah during the
world cup final 2006 i think it was when
italy won on penalties and saddam
um
yeah so my mum would always kick him out
yeah she'd always just when she'd had
enough just kick him out and it was very
much a case of i think my dad
loved my mum more than my mum loved my
dad and my dad was i think he'd admit he
was like the the kind of like lap dog
that would come running back my mom
would kick him out and he'd come back
and it'd be i'd see i'll see as a kid
like them have an argument it'd be
kicked out so unfairly like and i just i
wouldn't be able to work it out but i
kind of understood it because i was on
the receiving end of that
kind of judgment and and stuff sometimes
so i remember he would she'd always kick
him out he'd go around his friends and
i'd go and visit him as friends and
again he had a little box room as well
and he hated it and he was
a proper grafter working all the hours
under the sun so one day he just went
she's going to kick me out again and i'm
and i'm just gone and then and i'm just
going to go and
luckily like he didn't travel to the
other side of the world he just went to
a town
30 minutes up the road but yeah we was
watching a football game world cup and i
thought i better enjoy this because it's
going to be different after this and i
think it was a bit different after that
because i think
if
i if home life was ever bad he was
always the one that i'd be able to chat
to about it and that and then after
after that
it's a good job it was a good football
game otherwise that would have been [ __ ]
wouldn't it
was there um
was there a point you got to where you
kind of wanted your parents to separate
for
because i i fought it for a long time
and i was like i remember crying my eyes
out as a kid at the prospect of my
parents separating and then i remember i
think maybe getting to like 14 or 15
where i was like i'd actually prefer you
guys to not live in place yeah i think
that's accurate to me yeah i
i i don't know i'm just looking back
and seeing it differently but i don't
think i gave a [ __ ] really when it
happened i think it i'd all i'd always
see them break up and get back together
and break up and get back together and i
think like
i'd see my dad like stay up all night
writing my mum love notes and stuff and
she'd wake up not not be asked get rid
of him and i'd see that side of it as a
kid i don't think that should have been
a side that i i did see necessarily um
the the rejection from from her for
someone that she's supposed to love so
when he when he was gone i was kind of
like yeah go fly
yeah and then he met his new partner
who's lovely and then ever since then
that's been a little haven as well just
going around there and just venting and
stuff so did you ever figure out why she
was the way she is
did you ever try and figure it out was
it like a generational thing that was
her parents or something or something
had happened to her i don't know because
her mum
my nan is the loveliest woman in the
world
so i see my nan all the time i've got a
tattooed on me there
um
so i don't know where it came from i
just think she's she just has or she had
she might be completely different now
but she definitely just had issues and
i don't know whether that's drink drugs
whatever that may be um
maybe i haven't
given her enough time to actually think
about why she's like that really
i don't know and she's never had help or
anything like that not that i'm not as
far as i know no not as far as i know
but my life has been richer and mentally
i've been a lot healthier without her in
my life which sounds horrible um
but that's the that's the truth of it
maybe one day we'll be able to sit down
and talk it all talk it all through but
not not today and probably not tomorrow
what about school you in school what
were you like uh just a little i was
quite sure actually little ginger um
[ __ ]
really
i was all right
yeah i would just show off to the cool
kids i'd want to be i'd want to be
accepted a lot so i'd show off to the
cool kids and i remember i used to
always like
say what i think were
funny little one-liners and not get a
laugh and then once i put a ruler in a
fan and it went and i got the biggest
laugh ever and i thought what is this
what am i doing so i just became a bit
of an idiot in the last few years and
was just trying to make the
the cool kids laugh so there's a there
is a lot of regrets
for how i was at school as well because
i wasn't a bully i'd never say i was a
bully but i was a bit of a prick to
teachers as well there was one teacher
in
particular i'll just go in her class and
i just wouldn't be asked and i would
just never listen and she'd try
i wonder if in a in a weird way like
she'll stumble across this video and uh
miss chapman was her name english
teacher and i'd love to reconnect with
her and just apologize because i mean we
all were but that was no justification
for me individually but i was just a bit
of a prick i would never listen and i
guess being ginger and everyone's got
things that people like get picked on
for as a kid but you you try and you try
and fit in so i i try to fit in by being
the class clown the funny one and that's
such a cliche and i hate when people say
they were the class clown because what
that translates to is you were just a
bit of a [ __ ] and that's but that's
what i was so
yeah miss chapman if you if you're
watching this i apologize you were great
i hope she is oh i hope she is
was it just because you were ginger
though and you're being picked on a
little bit that you were trying to like
find a way for them to appreciate you
was that yeah you think that was it yeah
i discovered bleach
bleached my hair
i relaxed mine so it was straight no i'm
just i'm just cool with this short afro
thing right yeah well yeah i yeah i
discovered bleach and then i remember
just going to school the next day like
that scene in bruce almighty or i'm like
well you guys are flying on me
and i was yeah i was a different person
then um
yeah and then and then but then i was
predicted all the top grades like i was
predicted like 12 gcses or whatever it
was like top marks and everything and i
just completely [ __ ] it really and got
like five just scraped it so um
yeah i was a bit a bit of an idiot
really i only sort of took life serious
after school when thank god i found
youtube because god knows what i'd be
doing if i didn't
was was there a connection in your view
when you look back between your home
life and your school life
i think because you said it was it year
ten or eleven i can't remember that
things kind of went downhill for you i
wondered if there was there was a link
at what with in your mind of what was
going on at home and what you know your
school
performance decline um
maybe maybe maybe i could i could sort
of blame home life but i
i i probably wouldn't i'd probably just
say it was more a case of wanting to fit
in discovering at an early age i wanted
to be the funny one i've always been the
center of attention as well or wanted to
be the center of attention i should say
so as soon as i discovered oh
self-deprecating works i'm putting
myself down works that gets a laugh i'll
do that and then you're invincible then
because if people are calling you
a ginger [ __ ] if you call yourself a
ginger [ __ ] before then disarming yeah
now i've got the cards
yeah
yeah so i don't think the home like that
the home my home life affected school
probably the early years in high school
because like not to go into too much
detail but like things would happen at
home and i'd have like a mark on my face
like from
someone that shouldn't have given me
that mark
and i'd go to school and say the cat
done it
and i didn't have a cat
so so it's like
that really i think that really affected
me there's little things as well like
i remember like i had these
ornaments
snow white and the seven dwarves no i
don't think i've even seen the film but
i love these ornaments and then i'd done
something at home that was naughty or
something
stayed up too late or played the
playstation too much and then
someone came in and
threw the through the shelf down and
smashed those ornaments and i remember
as the shelf was on the floor
i remember thinking i was only a kid i
was probably like 10 right and the shelf
was on the floor there's a big standing
bookshelf and i was i remember thinking
please please don't say those ornaments
are broke i love them for some reason
and i remember lifting it up and they
were all broke and that was the moment
where i was kind of like i [ __ ] hate
this [ __ ] so i remember going to school
and having to deal with stuff like that
but in in the later years when i kind of
had youtube and found my feet a little
bit more and who i wanted to be i found
it a bit easier even if i was
pissing the grades up the wall so to
speak
do you ever worry because i it's
something i as i've gotten older i think
as we get older sometimes the like
some of the earlier things we learned
about love or relationships or how you
treat people or how you respond or your
temper they they can sometimes um
surface and you because i'd have moments
where i'd see parts of my parents and
myself that i maybe didn't love
have you ever
seen glimmers of that home life that you
think in yourself when you go [ __ ] i
don't want to be that person that's
that's such an amazing question that
it's like that's so
that me and my sister have discussed
this as well because i have
i have
because i because i
separated from my mom so to speak at
quite quite an early age just after
after school i think i've lost all of
her her traits that i had in me because
they were such negatives to me i really
noticed them like her biggest negatives
like stood out like a sore thumb so i
actively had to not take them on myself
um whereas my sister
she had she had quite a few of her
my mom's negative um traits and we've
spoken about this now as adults and
she's like yeah i have to actively like
whenever i think like mum would think or
do something mum would do have to try
and get rid of it i have a lot of my
i give my dad all the credit i have so a
lot of how i am is because of my dad but
i also have my dad's negative traits as
well which i think he would say and my
dad not so much now but especially after
what i told you about his upbringing
anger was his thing so and i have i have
that not luckily i have it under control
it's never going to affect anyone else
or hurt anyone else but like for example
if i'm editing and the software shuts
down i'm like [ __ ] like i'm re like
instantly i'm so angry inside and fiona
will have to be like jack just
chill the [ __ ] out like this isn't that
deep and then i'm like okay as long as i
remember where i got this from and what
if i can pinpoint on something i'm a lot
i'm a lot better um luckily that's never
got me into any trouble if i'm out and
someone says anything to me i i don't
get that i get it through over trivial
that sort of like trivial things
but yeah um i definitely do have have
some negative traits about me from my
parents have you ever gone to like
therapy or spoken to anybody to try and
understand these patterns or to spot
them or anything or is it just from like
self-reflection that you've noticed
um i did anger management classes at
school oh really yeah um but
they put me in them for something i
didn't do i remember walking in the
library once and i was at the bottom of
these stairs
and this guy just gets run down the
stairs at my feet and the teachers come
in and seeing it and i'd have to do 12
weeks anger i swear to i
promise you i've done a lot of like mad
[ __ ] at school but that was not one of
them i didn't know how i could throw him
and be down there before him he was on
my feet so it didn't make sense um so
yeah i remember doing twelve or six
weeks anger management um but i kind of
needed them so even though i didn't
actually join that it says i probably
would have been the guy to maybe do that
one day had i not had them i can't
remember anything we spoke about in
those lessons but
yeah that's the only time i've really
debated it does that does it does it not
ever crop up in
your professional work like anger issues
with
uh like colleagues or with i don't know
with people
no i think
i think i've over the years i've
mellowed out so much i've
i think i've matured so much as well and
i think that shines through in like my
old kind of like main channel content
because i made a name for myself on
youtube by being kind of like the
anti-youtuber yeah and like slagging off
other youtubers and but i remember
turning on the camera and putting on
such a fake anger because i was talking
about things i didn't care about oh
ollie white's got some new 30 pound
t-shirts let's moan about that mainly
because i knew i'd get a million views
from it not that i cared so i got really
good at turning the camera on and
putting this kind of like
faux like anger like fake out like i
guess because i was pretending to be
angry all the time
i was very alert when i actually was
angry and i could keep that keep that
under control so
do you regret any of those videos as
you've matured you said you've meddled
out matured now and you even spot that
you were doing them from like a not an
authentic place right do you regret them
uh there's some i definitely do regret
yeah the majority i'd say no
um
obviously we we we both know that i'm a
big fan of ricky gervais yeah and he
always one of his mantras is there needs
to be a why in comedy why are you doing
something if you're targeting someone
why are you doing it like um and a lot
of my
early main channel content like for
anyone who doesn't know like i made a
video reacting to um so well as advent
calendar everybody knows
it's got like six million views isn't it
yeah crazy it did all right that changed
the game for me in terms of youtube i
was i was going to quit the
the upload before that i was going to
quit and then i uploaded that video and
it changed the game but like when i look
back on videos like that i have no
regrets because it was funny it the
comedy almost like it wrote itself like
there was a reason why i was doing it it
was it was a sketch that's all it was
but there would be times when i fell
into the trap of like
okay people know jackmate
for
being the guy to slag stuff off and
that's funny whatever and then i'd find
a few things that naturally did piss me
off and i could draw humor from it and
then when the content dried up it was
kind of like well i've now got to go and
look for someone who's doing something
wrong and become this kind of like
sort of white knight of of the internet
sort of thing and it was like it's never
who i was so i i did my first ever video
with ricky gervais and and
that was the biggest moment ever for me
and then i remember uploading the video
and the interview was
brilliant
and the top comment was this is good
jack but ollie white's released some new
t-shirts that you haven't spoken about
and i thought [ __ ] me
so i've got now that's what you want
from me is that so then i'd go i'll then
go out of my way to go okay zoella are
in the title bang's views
what is she up to oh she's released the
book now that book there was nothing
wrong with that book
but i'm trying i'm tr actively trying to
pick flaws in it that i can dissect
on my channel and it's like there that's
kind of like the stuff i i i regret i
remember ksi and joe weller they did
their when i was trying to be edgy boy
edgy boy jack mate they did their first
press conference for their fight and
that was in
in manchester i think it was and and
because i was the black sheep of youtube
i would never get invited to them so
therefore by default the jealousy would
take over and i'd be like this is [ __ ] i
want nothing to do with it we're deep
down i knew that i wanted something to
do with that that whole youtube boxing
scene i'm a boxing fan i'm a youtube fan
so why would that not appeal to me um
and they they did a press conference
and jj he um he said something about joe
weller's medication which i don't agree
with but in the context of a press
conference you say anything you can to
get the upper hand and i remember just
turning on my camera straight away i was
like ksi needs to be cancelled blah blah
blah because i knew it would bang views
but jj is a hero of mine as i'm sure he
is to any youtuber any content creator
no joe weller i was i i used to watch
every single one of his videos i i love
joe weller so they're the ones i regret
when i wasn't being authentic and not
even really being funny
just actually trying to
go in on someone
because i wanted that check at the end
of the the ad revenue to be higher that
month when you were doing that so when
you
jj mentioned the medication thing you
hit record was it like i can make some
money here or is it i can make some
money and get attention
probably a bit of both yeah because they
go hand in hand don't they especially
especially on youtube so probably a bit
of both um
it's mad that you're so self-aware about
this like and you're just like
you're really good at diagnosing
exactly why you did it from like a
psychological incentive perspective
you're like i wanted this so i did this
i wasn't true to myself i did it and it
and that
suggests like you've done a lot of kind
of reflecting and soul searching and
maturing in what is actually a very
short space of time
because this is only this is not you
know a lifetime this is not a decade ago
that video was probably
four and a half five years ago yeah tops
yeah yeah it's because it was i i
realized a couple of years ago it wasn't
who i wanted to be
i was probably i i recently did a brand
trip with cal freezie and the burnt um
the burnt chip and i was speaking to
them out one night and i'd never done
a trip with another youtuber i was
always youtubers are very clicky and
they're all in their groups
um and i was always on the outside of
that i was always this boy from norwich
just have my normal mates and they
surround themselves with youtubers and i
remember saying to them one night
i think the main reason why i used to go
for him is because i wanted to be him i
i i'm i'm one of the ogs i really am
i've been doing youtube
probably around this to the the same
month that jj uploaded his first one
like we would have been there at the
start and cal frizzy calyx all of these
lads uh mini minter and i and i probably
i see them become a collective and i was
like why am i not part of that like and
now i don't give a [ __ ] i'm so happy and
content with where i'm at and i've built
my podcast now and but but as a as a kid
as a
even as an 18 19 year old young man
growing up seeing that feeling left out
it probably goes back to how i was at
school as well i thought okay
if if if you if you can't join them
slag them off become the darth vader of
youtube so to speak um
yeah and then in recent years people
started to discover that other people
that i really respected like will any
people on you and then even though will
was my friend like i still is my friend
like he'd call me out publicly when i'd
be slagging someone off and go have a
day off mate and i would be so angry
because because it was accurate and i'm
like i'm sat there like
so right no i'm not bothered mate like
that kind of that kind of thing so
yeah
yeah i'm speaking to cal for easy about
that and
yeah i've got a lot i've got nothing but
respect for it for him now my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete and
that has about 100 calories in total
while also giving you 20 grams of
protein
if you haven't tried the cured protein
product do give it a try the salted
caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you
hill for making a product that i
actually like the salted caramel is my
favorite i've got the banana one here
which is the one my girlfriend likes but
for me salted caramel is
the one
you not only did the whole youtube thing
but you also provided this like online
commentary
almost constantly about how you were
feeling about it so you're one of the
sort of rare youtubers that like in real
time would say i've lost motivation for
this i'm going to try and find my
motivation for this i've lost motivation
for doing this kind of thing i'm doing
that you know what i mean and you were
very open so even for me i as i looked
into twitter i could kind of see where
you are on this journey obviously i've
seen that change a lot with the whole
podcast and the spotify thing which
feels like you really found something
that you do find like really enjoyable
but with your main channel i watched you
go through these waves of enjoyment and
then
seeing you say well i'm gonna try and
commit to it now and then that didn't
really work and then so tell me about
that journey with youtube and what you
learned about yourself from that
oh god it's really good questions it's
got to be said like wait till you come
on my podcast
your favorite sandwich i genuinely have
watched it and this is why i kept trying
to you know message you about come on my
podcast because
that watching that journey taught me so
many things and it really reconfirmed a
lot about for me that i've been reading
about in psychology about what keeps
people motivated and when they're not
doing things that are in line with who
they are or whether they're doing it for
a check i remember reading this study
which said
if you love doing something and then
they pay you to do the exact same thing
you lose your motivation so the minute
it goes from being a hobby i'm doing for
the love of it to a hobby that i love
doing but now someone is paying me for
there's this weird thing that happens in
the mind where people lose motivation
for the exact same thing
going off that and i'm not sure if this
answers your question but i found this
really interesting i couldn't really
work out myself
i
spent
my whole
youtube kind of main channel era like
just saving up all my money just saving
up all my money like the only thing i
was
i had the blinkers on i was like
buy a house buy a house buy a house buy
a house and last may
i paid for my house and bought it
outright and
that was the last time bar won that was
the last time i uploaded
really
yeah
it was like it's called a rival fallacy
i think yeah yeah and tyson fury has had
it about um when he beat klitschko and
became the heavyweight champion of the
world the next day he was depressed
israel had a son you sat there yesterday
into the same thing really he said the
day after i won the ufc title i went to
my hotel room i was depressed yeah i
said it last night on stage at the
palladium i said 80 of olympians when
they get the gold medal they they report
depressive symptoms yeah
it was the most proud proudest i've ever
been over at anything and
paid it off and then me and my partner
fiona we
we moved in in september and i just
i remember just i was drunk one night
and i remember just walking around my
house when fiona was asleep and i just
i just didn't care for the for where i
was like it's a beautiful house and i'm
so lucky and it's everything i've worked
for but it was like what do i do now
then like what do i
where like what i'll sit on my sofa or
go and go in my kitchen i just know i
said i'm not any happier than when i was
renting or
um
it was it was weird so
have you figured out why you felt that
way
no i know
nah i don't know i don't know it's it's
because it's because the journey is way
more fun than amen yeah than than the
arrival
that it just it just is the
the most fun i've ever had is probably
the first time i got a viral video or
the first time i got to present for this
company or first time i got a brand deal
do all the stereotypical youtuber things
the first time i felt like a youtuber
they they're the best moments and
it's i'm not i'm not complaining i'm not
sitting here and whining and i'm so
blessed and so lucky and
yeah it is a it is a tough one it's a
tough one but like i did
my kind of like sound bite that i always
sort of say is i did youtube for seven
years without earning a penny
and then and then once the zoella video
kicked off and the ad revenue went up
and i earned money i would never i could
never dream of earning
that
that was no more fun than when i was
doing it for
for free and it's funny because the i
guess the liberating thing to know is
that
everyone i've sat here with says the
same thing so it's not a you thing it's
a human thing and so you go okay if it's
a human thing what does that mean and
why is that one of the things because i
was writing my show for the palladium i
i encountered was that the reason why
we're here is because our ancestors
struggled forward and their desire to
keep striving is the reason they built
these empires and overcame so i say to
the crowd i say is it conceivable that
they left a message within our genetic
code that says you too shall struggle
forward and they've kind of like
predisposed us to like forward motion
and also this other point like the our
ancestors are ancestors that had a
a real sense of
what really liked forward motion
struggle and purpose were the ones that
survived and passed on their genes to us
so where we've inherited this real
desire to have forward motion and a
sense of purpose and one of the things
they say is causing the life expectancy
to decline in the western world is
specifically they they point at men and
say there's a epidemic of
purposelessness as the world is starting
to change and ai and things like this
are i'm pointing at the little robot
that's moving moving up around the room
on its own are taking purpose from
people and so people are now becoming
more addicted and depressed and there
for their suicide has become the single
killer biggest killer of men under the
age of 45 which has caused the life
expectancy to decline for two years in a
row and it's because of they think this
epidemic of purposeless so when you lose
your sense of purpose
because you reach the the point you're
aiming for that can be so disorientating
and confusing as it was for me at 25
when someone came along and said we'll
buy a social chain off you for 50
million and i go home and i look at the
the mansion on rightmove and the
lamborghini on auto trader and i feel
totally [ __ ] lost i can i completely
i completely agree like i i wouldn't
change it for the world it's everything
i've i've always
always wanted but like because because i
i think i think money does money does
buy happiness and i think if people say
otherwise i think they're talking [ __ ]
like
in a way like
well well maybe i should rephrase that
to to
money buys freedom yeah and freedom is
is happiness and that's what what i have
now i have i can do what i want when i
want the best feeling i i i get now as a
28 year old soon to be 29 year old is
when i sort my family out
and
like my granddaddy's still working he's
20 days 70 um 77 20. imagine that he
wishes
he's 70 he's 77 he's a big fat lump from
norfolk and he still does building and
demolition and walks on routes and stuff
and he's not got a penny and then like
i went to see his parents grave with him
in
february um last year and uh he goes
there every week puts new flowers on
he's been doing it for like 50 years and
it's like and i could see
he was he was wearing these beat up
boots and this disgusting tattered
jacket and i just went home and i just
got his bank card without him knowing
from his side of his car where his
handbrake is i got his bank and i just
transferred him five thousand pounds and
for me that was like that was just
everything that was like that was a
everything i'd worked for was justified
in that moment and i got more out of
that than i did when i bought my house
and
like just little things like my sister's
type one diabetic so she has like a
thing in her arm that constantly pricks
her and finds her levels and i can i can
pay for that [ __ ] and yeah last night my
dog died and the dog that i'd had for 18
years um
and
literally like found out just before i
went to sleep last night and it's little
things like this that might not seem
like a lot but
it was the first time i'd spoke to my
mum in ages and she was like oh yeah
we're going to get diddy's ashes cost
200 pounds there's the 200 pounds so
it's like that kind of [ __ ] is like
why i owe everything to this online
world and people that have given up
their time to watch me and brands that
have trusted me and stuff and
yeah that's the best feeling i think you
nailed it when you said that i'm sorry
about your dog by the way i have a dog
and i really don't really i can't
imagine
it's [ __ ] it's really [ __ ] even the
thought of it is just terrifying she was
18 years and four months which is quite
old but when they get to that age you
just assume that they're always going to
crack on yeah yeah
um no you i think you nailed it when you
said that freedom is the thing that
ultimately does make you happier because
i remember not having i remember getting
the bailiff letters and then not being
not knowing how i was going to eat or
knowing that the landlord was going to
come and ask me why i paid the rent in
four months and the pressure that of
course that like weighing on me and the
freedom of just like not looking at how
much things cost when you go into top
man i want to buy one of those t-shirts
yeah that kind of thing or you want to
go somewhere so freedom definitely makes
you happier but obviously at this point
i've come to realize that if you gave me
more money
the the fundamental happiness levers of
my life won't change like
you're right like my sister's been a
little bit sick recently she um
um and being able to help her i said to
my team this week i was like that's the
moment where i see the point of this
just being able to like pay the hospital
or like get a check to get it get a
proper health care those kind of things
um my parents got broken into and being
able to buy them like new locks for
their doors so that they wouldn't get
broken into again is is one of those
things where you go that's what this is
for yeah that's what that was the
feeling yeah it makes it all worthwhile
doesn't it completely do you
do you ever feel
again name drop but i spoke to gervais
about this because i was really i was
really
something that plagues me whether it's
right or wrong is
i feel guilty about having money
i feel i feel this
sense of guilt where it's like
and i don't have crap i don't have crazy
money like i've my situation is i paid
off my house i have a bit more in the
bank like that's what it is but i
because because of my upbringing and
where i'm from and i see my dad wake up
at 5 00 a.m every morning go work in a
factory for 12 hours and then still
struggle to buy christmas presents and
then i'm like you just said i go online
i don't look at the price of things
anymore
i just buy it and then it's like what
like this doesn't make sense i'll tell
you a quick story
three four years ago my dad's dad my
grandad he passed away he got um
bone cancer or some kind of [ __ ] cancer
they're all [ __ ] i guess and um
he
i went to his funeral
went to the wake had a few jars
went back home went on a night out
and i was in the place called the
waterfront in norwich which is where i
always i always go
i go there because i'm comfortable
because everyone knows me there now so i
don't get the [ __ ] come over and
whatever but so they've if if jack
mate's in there they've already seen
jack mate 100 times so it doesn't matter
and this guy cat and i was i was gone
and i was not in a good place and this
guy came up to me and said
i've never met him before and he asked
me how much i earned from youtube and i
think it's such a rude question but i
can understand the intrigue in it
because it's a world that people just
don't know it's a new world i barely
know it and um he asked me and i just
told him for the first time ever i was
like this is what i am i said what about
you what do you want
and he told me it was like 10 10 of what
i am and i said what do you do he said i
work in the cancer ward at the hospital
and i was just like and i weren't saying
what do you do to be rude i was just
throwing that back at him and i remember
just thinking
it just hit me just got a lump in my
throat and i thought why
why do i
do i deserve this what i have when
there's these people that are like
they're the [ __ ] angels they're the
ones walking around
doing that like i just
yeah i struggled to then wrap my head
around why a brand would pay me
30k
to do a video like it doesn't
it to me
it's weird so
i guess you could argue why don't you
give it all to charity well
i'm not gonna do that but i will give it
all to my [ __ ] family and i will give
it all to my [ __ ] kids
and that's what makes me proud
is there this is like a wider point
about imposter syndrome is it
i i i think so because um
because i've never struggled with the
idea that i didn't deserve what i'd
created and i think so i'm asking myself
why you would really struggle with that
while you might struggle with
the thought that you're making money and
other people are potentially having to
because that i mean it's a reality of
the world even if you go back to where i
was born in africa people in the fields
for 18 hours a day picking tea leaves in
the baking sun get paid nothing
and in the western world
some people can just play around on
their computer and make billions yeah
from the
stock market or the markets or something
but for some reason you struggle you
struggle with
this and other symptoms of imposter
syndrome from what i've read and
maybe it's
because i think i spoke positively about
youtubers and my peers and stuff but
there's still a lot of them that are
pricks like and and
and
and and growing up and seeing like i'd
used to go to youtube events and see my
youtube heroes and then come over how
many subscribers you got it's the first
thing i'd say how many subscribers you
got my name's jack nice to meet you
[ __ ] right
so i guess i guess maybe it's connecting
that i'm now a youtuber i'm now i i now
make my money in the same way that alfie
dave's mate made his money ollie white
makes his money i'm that guy and because
i've seen a lot of youtubers take it for
granted and just assume that that's
their right to have these things it
that's maybe where i get my guilt from i
never want to lose lose touch of that
and and you really come from a working
class like household where you've
watched your dad work really really hard
and everyone around you it sounds like
work really really hard wherever you've
looked
and it's almost like you found a bit of
a cheat code or you know yeah you might
feel like life has given you i don't
know
but you've you earned it i mean you
bought the whiteboard yeah
right this was intentional
yeah
the workbook shows that you you know you
planned it out
obviously
moments of luck for all of us appear
when we we start we carry on carrying on
but you realize that you've earned it
right
yeah you do you hesitate
you don't do
i i
i do and i but not to the level
in which i've got to now not to like
yeah i get i i guess i guess i i i have
i have i have a talent i can do i'm a
personable person i can
make people laugh but yeah i don't i
don't know i don't i really don't know
how to answer it i get
i've thought about it a lot i've racked
my brains a lot about this what does
your brain say to you when you rack your
brain i don't know it's just
maybe i don't but then
like it's it's it's cool things like
this like stevie white my my podcast
co-host was working in boots nothing
wrong with that it's a respectable job
um just a nine to five he didn't
particularly enjoy it um
so i call him up one day and say let's
do a podcast a year later he's
interviewing ricky gervais johnny
knoxville rob bride and he's left his
job he's doing it full time
fiona my partner she was working at a
supermarket i was telling her for years
ben it off i'll teach you how to edit
you become my editor
a couple of years go by she brings it
off she's now working for me there's a
few examples of people in my life that
can now
have an easier life
because of the foundations that i put in
seven years ago
that's
that's what i love and that's when i'm
like i i just i deserve this and the
people around me deserve it does that
make sense of course it does once again
you said that like the most fulfilling
thing for you is helping others right
you said that about your family yeah now
also for profession it's like giving
those people opportunities to live a
better life yeah we're just a [ __ ]
team we're just a team they help me as
well it's not just me going look i can
help you do this i showed them that
there's a there's a different world out
there because people like us we've been
in this world for so long we've seen the
opportunities but they probably didn't
so yeah i wouldn't be able to do what i
do without that that kind of
the team in the in the background or
sometimes in the foreground with people
like stevie but yeah um that's a [ __ ]
cool feeling everybody um everybody it
sounds like it feels like everybody
that's not a youtuber and i say
everybody because there's gonna be
people listening that are driving up
around the country right now as they're
listening to this or you know doing the
dishes whatever and perfectly happy with
whatever they're doing but a lot of
young people want to be youtubers and
the thought that you had this like big
main channel with like how many subs is
your main channel got now it's like one
point four or so yeah 1.4 million yeah
um
that you would like lose motivation to
do it is quite a
difficult concept to understand for a
lot of people you have 1.4 million
people that have subscribed to get
videos from you and you're like can't be
asked yeah it's not so much can't be
asked it's just it's not me it's just
it's just not me anymore it's people i
i'd open up my inbox and people would be
emailing me about some youtuber from
france who has
sold a pen for a bit too much money and
i need to be the guy that calls them out
and it was just like i was never i was
never really this guy so
yeah i i guess i guess i just
transferred all that energy that i was
putting into the main channel into the
podcast and that's where my passion is
now and doing stuff like this getting to
sit here and chat to you and
yeah that's i i get what you mean like
if you'd have asked me two years ago am
i just going to leave a channel with 1.4
million subscribers stagnant i would
i'd call you all the names under the sun
i'd be like you're an idiot of course
i'm not going to do that but it seems
that i have done it i'll use it every
now and then like in january i uploaded
a video about boris johnson and i saw a
dope video
all over the newspapers really really
cool video thank you like creatively
culturally relevant
it really like hit it was fast you were
very quick to act on that moment so it
was uh
that i guess i guess for you probably is
that how you you're seeing the use of
your youtube your main channel now like
when you genuinely feel you want to do
something yeah yeah yeah
like
when the the why is there when there's a
clear and obvious why i'll i'll do it
um
and not just for a quick buck now i'm
very thankful i don't need to do them
anymore it's hard to sustain something
when it's not in line with who you truly
are yeah it's hard to like sustain it
for a long period of time in the short
term you could probably do it but it
tends to be the case when i say with
people that at any point in their lives
where they were living outside of
themselves like living someone else's
life or kind of like fern cotton said it
like she had to like go on radio and be
this happy
and um
almost play a character jake humphrey
said it to me as well like because he
was a presenter having to kind of like
put on the mask eventually it becomes a
really heavy mask to wear and they all
eventually it seems kind of choose to
throw it away and just rebound and that
seems similar to what you're saying 100
yeah i i
i told this story last night to someone
i can't remember
i i used to turn the camera on i used to
go
i'd be sat there and i'd turn the camera
on okay
right guys hello it's me jack mate arves
zoella oh what [ __ ] well she's done
this done that
turn the camera off just sit there and i
couldn't tell you anything i just said
in the last 20 minutes i'm just looking
down at my script she said this in her
book about how out of touch is it
and it would just be like
right that's the ad revenue sorted for
the month
fee let's go to weatherspoons
yeah so it was like you can only do that
for so long before you
just hate yourself
there is an element of that in me like
that that the advent calendar video i've
done some videos i'm really proud of
funny videos when when it was
when it was justified but there's also
ones it's not so much i've been doing
recent sort of commentary videos over
the last two years my my recent ones are
like videos i've been doing with my
friend alfie indra who's a musician and
we've been like sort of
taking kind of comical pokes that people
like um jeremy lynch from the f2 and
people like that and and i see people
think i'm jeremy lynch oh really you do
you don't want to be you don't want to
be that guy
you can be billy be the other one he
seems all right but um but the thing
with those videos i'm really proud of
them still and i guess you could argue
well you're that same kind of like
scathing um commentator yeah but i i
believe that those people i'm going for
they're justified
zoella not so much let her crack on
you know
what would you say to her have you ever
met her never met her
i don't think she wants to meet me
that'd be an awkward one wouldn't it
is there like is there any
because that video did really well yeah
and i think if a video about me had
gotten six million views um i think i'd
have a pretty shitty month
i was going to say weak but i think it'd
last longer because that video did
really really well i remember like
sometimes someone will write like an
article about me and i try and do this
stuff coming i don't give a [ __ ]
whatever whatever but i'm still at like
1am in the morning it'll like it it's
hard to get it out of my mind so i think
if a video had got 6 million views about
me criticizing something i'd done yeah
it probably been quite hard to take
mentally yeah do you have has that ever
like crossed your mind like ever
yeah
i'm not saying what you did was
wrong because i watched the video and i
actually thought it was really funny
so it's like was there comedic merit in
someone that's super successful selling
a advent calendar of that nature for
that price yes i understand it like when
you talk about the why and it's your
face like philosophy i get it but does
has that crossed your mind as well
yeah yeah um like that's just another
reason why i stopped doing it um
it's hard to
i'm not articulate enough to describe
how i feel about it but yeah the
the calendar video was funny there was a
clear error on her behalf and i just
ultimately i
i wasn't really saying anything nasty
about her it was just this product
whereas when you do a follow-up video
and a third video
where's the where's the line where do
you draw the line is it becoming
bullying now like that's not who i want
to be i want to be a comedian so
so i definitely as i've gotten older and
i guess maybe i was immature for a long
time i should have realized this at a
way earlier age than i did but
you do start to consider
others
um and and i'm the same as you mate i'll
read a comment about me on twitter and i
will clap back and i still go back to
them now and fees they're going what are
you doing and i'm like [ __ ] him like i
just like that's a bit of my dad as well
like and i'll just i'll spend hours
arguing with football twitter
all the worst yeah yeah yeah they've all
got like a football player as their
display pitch yeah yeah like fantastic
four now
he doesn't know who you are
yeah but i i get a bit of a rash from it
really
i i i worry sometimes because i say to
myself i'm trying to reply to a troll to
try and disprove their point or because
it's fun or whatever but i think
sometimes it's because it's like hit me
in the ego yeah and i don't want to
admit to myself that person's actually
pissed me off yeah so i kind of use the
guise of no it's funny or like no like
to to justify it to everyone and i was
like i'm not bothered
i really i really you know the internet
is not a good place to be if you haven't
got control over that because you'll get
dragged around by trolls with egg emoji
accounts like yeah yeah
yeah i i i
like i said fees always telling me not
don't sh i'll be in bed like that
hungover or whatever sunday morning
going on and fee will be like just leave
it they're [ __ ] idiots and ultimately
i know
they're probably just jealous of
whatever it is like i'll get like a good
podcast guest on and like the other day
i was in um
i was in wales with gerwyn price he's
the number one dance player in the world
and um put a picture up of me and him
just put
in beautiful whales thrown a few arrows
with going price and going price is this
panto villain i don't know how much you
know about darts but he's like the panto
villain welsh one yeah that when he wins
always like didn't he smack them it goes
like this yeah biceps yeah yeah yeah
yeah um and and and so he's i've heard
for a while that he's he's always he's
very lovely off camera but or off the
stage but when he's up there he's a
panto villain that's pretty much like
the jack mate of darts in a way so i put
up this picture of him i was like never
judge a book by its cover like i know
this more than i know this myself
because i always did it's just just this
guy replied two bellins as well but he
follows me just follows me so it's like
i i will reply to him and he's like why
are you bothered like that must just be
jealousy like why else do you
well you follow me and you're and you're
doing that like it doesn't make sense
but i i kind of like
i like to think that i'm very very
honest online
so why would i not reply
why would i not try and think of some
pithy
remark to try and put him down like
yeah because i'm meant to be a
professional and i'm in this world and
i'm working for west ham but really i
also think you're a bit of a [ __ ]
right and i'll tell you do you think
that because you are very like um
i imagine if like boris johnson and like
i don't know another politician uploaded
a photo you'd probably quote retweet and
say two ballons so like do you think
there's a chance because i i don't think
anyone would ever tweet me that like
do you think there's a because you've
cultivated a younger male audience that
are comedic and they're like they use
kind of
kind of colloquialistic funny language
like bellends yeah
you're also now
at the mercy of them attacking you with
the same language
in that situation i'm just wondering why
no one would ever tweet me if i uploaded
a photo two bell ends
i just my audience just don't speak like
that wait for this episode
you see what i mean like and then you're
having to deal with that because i get
what you mean yeah but then maybe they
see a bit of because because i yeah yeah
they think you maybe like that as well
they think oh jack you know because he
follows you and he you know he clearly
looks up to you if he's following you
and
hashtag that's true it's true it becomes
more real when you like
when like someone some there'll be
people out there that will defend me on
that thread and they'll say you don't
know him and he'll go but he looks like
a prick look at his trousers and then
he's like it's like personal yeah it
goes a bit it goes a bit deeper then but
like you are right because i i would
always do um an event called summer in
the city it was the only time i'd ever
i'd ever get out of like norwich and go
and meet the fans and they'd put you in
a pen and there'd be all these youtubers
in this big hall at like excel and
you're being a pen and then
fans come up one by one
and i'd meet like 13 year old girls you
might want to believe this i don't know
but they'd come up to me and go all
right you can't and i'll be like
what have you just said and then but
then because that's what i'm doing
online all right you [ __ ] [ __ ]
but they're there to meet me and they
want their thing signed so they like me
but they think
but then i wouldn't go up to like i
wouldn't go to declan right and start
doing keep you up
around the world right
then you just i just have to be like
yeah maybe
i am the influencer [ __ ]
scary scary notion no one's ever said
that to me in a meet and greet um
it's really interesting and you there's
an element of
do you think there's an element of your
childhood in that in the sense of like
being triggered a little bit by
what people are saying or the criticisms
that you know triggers you maybe
because i i definitely i'm thinking
about myself i definitely wouldn't sit
in bed replying especially now i'm on
the bbc like bbc one is a bit
prestigious in it i can't really yeah be
popping off too much yeah
well
yeah probably i probably shouldn't be
either do you do you want to be the type
of person that doesn't
yeah but i can't steve i can't like i'll
i'll reply to them and then and then fee
will be like
delete them and then and then i'll be
like no not gonna and then in an hour
it's like
so i could come down i'm like all right
now i'll delete them and then in an hour
later someone else just said something
what do you mean i'm so immature on
twitter it's
a joke there's a real risk they've been
like pulled around emotionally though by
the external world right yeah i've
deleted i've i've deleted twitter off my
phone a few times um
yeah we went i went out for a dinner
with max fosh and um i told him about he
was he questioned it he was like why'd
you always go back at these idiots i'm
like i'll just find it funny or they
just get to me and i deleted twitter off
my phone and he was like
i said i'm going to do it for the whole
weekend and he was like i guarantee that
you'll you'll re-download that by the
end of the meal and i have
i didn't was scrolling there looking
through it so when football twitter say
we're in your edge mate
nine times out of ten you are in the
head
but i'll try and get back in yours
do you not think it would be a happier
life just to [ __ ] like
100 yeah
yeah but i guess i get bored
is it that
yeah
quick one as many of you know i've been
trying to make my life a little bit more
sustainable as it relates to energy ever
since i sold my range over sport and
bought an electric bicycle and my energy
as a sponsor of this podcast is one of
the brands that make that transition
much much easier they are at the
forefront of british renewable ecosmart
technology and their products are really
really changing the game if you're on
youtube you can see what i'm holding in
my hand this is called the eddie right
it's the uk's number one solar powered
diverter so what is a solar diverter
it's a device for people like you and me
that means you can divert your excess
energy back into your home rather than
back into the grid which will save you
power and money it's super user friendly
and easy to install and you can control
it using the my energy app on your phone
to find out more about this product and
more products like it that will help you
make that sustainable transition head
over to myenergy.com and um i highly
recommend you check out the eddie it's
um it's a real game changer for a
product and one that i'm going to be
installing in my home soon
happy hour so this was a really pivotal
moment where did that start why did you
decide to start doing long-form podcasts
instead of the other types of videos you
were making before
i've i've always wanted to interview
people at college 10 years ago i studied
interview techniques really my grandad
was the first person i interviewed he
came in and i interviewed him about the
war and all that kind of stuff and i
always wanted to do it and then in
2017 i had a podcast with my friend tom
norris
um
done all right uh but it was just too
much too much um
we don't know the youtube space and we'd
rock up sometimes and they didn't have
the cameras in and that so it fell by
the wayside but then uh 2018 i wanted to
do another podcast
i said to fee
i said who should i do it with because i
always knew i wanted to do it with yeah
every man so not a youtuber because
that's not i'm not a youtuber that's
been friends with youtubers i'm a
youtuber that's friends with my mates in
norwich i'll do the best video ever with
the big celebrity come back to norwich
and they'll just go yeah we didn't watch
it mate not bothered and i'll just be in
the pub and that will be everything i
need to keep me grounded so i so she
suggested stevie white who's um just um
just a mate that lived in bristol and uh
i called him up and said you want to do
a podcast and he said why that's a good
voice
good point and then we ended up giving
it a go i started doing it with a guy
called i'm alex who's a youtuber that
was very um
a comment he was a commentary youtuber
so he was calling out people he would do
the cookie cutter templates of like x y
and z needs to be cancelled x one z
needs to be he was doing that all the
time so originally my show was a youtube
drama show to call people out to be an
extension of what i was doing on the
main channel and then after about five
or six episodes i thought this is just
poisonous and
i don't it's not me why am i trying to
do it in a different format so we
dropped that and started getting guests
on and interviewing people and
i found the love of
youtube again which i'd which had lost
for a few years
was there like a pivotal moment in happy
hour where you thought [ __ ] this is
going to be
was it wasn't the spot if i did it it
must have come sooner than that right
where you thought this is we've got
something here yeah um
again it was probably getting gervais on
oh because i can't remember that day he
was in our first like
three guests
and and i'm so grateful that he gave me
a chance years ago because i would i
genuinely believe i would have none of
this if it wasn't for him giving me a
shot and i built up a connection with
him years ago so he then when i needed
someone big to come on the podcast he
would step in and you know what it's
like you get one through the door other
people almost then don't
judge the show based on me
they'll judge it based on who who else
is sat in that seat yeah so
so i i owe a lot to him so that was
probably a defining moment and testament
to stevie as well because
i've been doing this for 10 12 years
i've been around people like gervais
i've been very lucky very fortunate and
i remember how nervous i was the first
time i sat on the sofa with him the
first time i filmed with him was the
most nervous i've ever been for anything
in my life and then stevie white has
come literally seemingly out of boots
the day before and then he sat there
with ricky and he's just
she gets it he's just on and he's just
the glue and i was like i've chosen the
right person there like to do this this
journey with
and then the money side of things so
eventually you get approached by spotify
and they they offer you um a contract or
a deal exclusive deal to do i remember
watching your video announcing that yeah
and you were very very honest
no like i think that's probably why
people like you so much because you're i
can trust you
because you're going to tell me the way
you go listen you know the money is a
[ __ ] very important thing and you've
been very
overt about that which i think is
admirable because again it builds trust
people don't have to like what you're
saying but they're going to trust you
they're going to trust you to always be
honest with them so
um what was your thinking around the
spotify deal because you know
i don't know someday spotify might
approach me and ask me if i want to um
if i want to go spotify exclusive and
maybe you can give me some advice on
that
um
the reason i did it was purely financial
i thought it was going to be a bad idea
and i took some
my network what i'm saying too they
wanted it to happen because obviously
they've got a slice of the pie did they
do they orchestrate the deal or did the
spotify go to them
and then to you yeah okay and um
originally i saw it as okay i'm taking
off the full visual episodes on youtube
and just putting them on an audio based
platform whereas a lot of my audience
might be the younger kids and people
like me and you would probably consume a
lot of just audio when we're on the go
and in the car and that whereas i think
younger generations and i'm basing this
on nothing you probably know better than
i do but i imagine younger kids probably
like the more visual they like to watch
these so i thought taking it off is is
probably going to get a lot of backlash
and then spotify told me how much it
would be
per year and the potential for how many
years and i thought well that doesn't
just change my life that changed my
children's life who don't even exist so
i literally did it because i was
financially driven um and i i've got no
qualms saying that or admitting that but
what i'll also say is i
now i'm starting to see the benefits a
year in of going with spotify and
they're not they've not got a gun to my
head i can be as honest as i want about
it if i thought it was [ __ ] i wouldn't
have then signed on for the second year
but they are now pulling out guests for
us um that i would have never been able
to pull on my own up until like two
months ago i'd booked every single one
of my guests
but personally on twitter dms or
instagram or whatever the last few
months they've booked us
johnny knoxville as part of his jackass
um
press junkets
rob brydon
russell howard um
we've got talks of some big
the biggest movie stars in the world
because of spotify so as somebody who
has always wanted to sit down with the
most interesting people in the world and
pick their brains they've offered
they've allowed me that so
and they've also said that i can get the
full video on spotify if i want and the
only reason i'm not doing that is for a
few things behind the scenes that i need
to
well i can say it can't it's because i'm
earning money on the youtube clip so
it's like you need to give me a little
bit more to take to take that off so it
needs to be worth your while yeah yes
i've actually had a conversation with
spotify about that as well about that
video thing and i was i was considering
it spotify said
um to me do i want to move the video to
spotify as well right and again me and
jack were trying to weigh up what that
means does that
because we're not going to get paid for
that on spotify but would our
would that does that mean we'd lose
youtube viewers if we moved it there
would people and we kind of concluded
that we wouldn't because we think that
as you've said they're kind of very
different types of people the youtube
watcher is not the necessarily the
spotify right people seem to be in their
habits they're like cycles of how they
consume content i don't know
don't know we've been debating that but
yeah but then
i don't know because
if i'm listening to one of your apps
i'll put
i'll put yeah i'll put the youtube
version on even if i'm not watching it
same
yeah same
yeah but then if it was if it was on
spotify would i then go to spotify for
that like i i don't i don't know i i
honestly do not know
i like i like the arrangement i have now
where people can watch the little clips
on youtube yeah and listen to the full
ones on spotify it's like advertising as
well isn't it because that can go like
viral on youtube and then that brings
people over to watch the full thing yeah
for sure which makes a lot of sense
what's your big vision as it relates to
like the next five ten years for happy
hour
um we i want to do a live show oh really
yeah we've been contacted a few times
about doing a live show but it just has
to be right
we actually did like a like a pilot one
in london somewhere a few years ago but
it was the old show with alex and uh
yeah um so so so yeah i want to tour it
um
i want to have a
more official chat show
i don't know what that means because i
have a chat show but is that on
television i don't know is it i don't
know i want a better studio
i just want to keep i'm really [ __ ]
happy mate so i just want to keep doing
what i'm doing and just make it bigger
and better and
just see what happens ever
thursdays which is today a day of
recording like my best days of the week
like i used to live for the weekend to
get pissed and go out with my friends
now i live for thursdays because i love
like after this we've got going price on
mine and then you're coming online as
well and like i'm so excited for both
conversations like that's so i just want
to keep doing it
it's the most impossible question when
people ask me where do you want to be in
five years i want to be i want to be
here yeah one of the things that um
you've also been really open about
especially in 2019 i saw you talking a
lot about this was that was a really
tough year for you right and you talked
a lot about your sort of mental health
battles and just not feeling so good
yeah i struggle with um health anxiety
and ocd and i remember that was a time
when i was i was really really low
um
and again i think i've touched on a few
times but probably going out a bit too
much and
doing the stuff i shouldn't have been
doing and and that it goes hand in hand
isn't it you feel [ __ ] because
the ocd is consuming you so you go out
to get pissed up to have a break but
then the next day is
anxiety or whatever they call it now is
um twice as bad so yeah 2019 i think was
really when that started to get really
bad and i still have it now um it's
never going to go away
but it's a really weird
really weird thing to
deal with health anxiety
yeah so when i was when i was young 13 i
found a lump downstairs
and um
like i found that like with
with certain words like testicles balls
stuff i struggle to say him i physically
struggle to say him when i'm talking to
fiona i'll say the t word or whatever
and because i remember i was up all
night worried that i had
the c that i
i were panicked and i was so [ __ ]
nervous i remember going to the doctor
and he had to check it out and said oh
it's fine it's just the cyst it will go
away
and it never went away
and i still have it now but the hell
thing's like this how mad it is i can't
touch that part of my body
i can't look at that part of my body i
can't go that
there's probably 15
to 20 times a day where i actually
convince myself that i have cancer that
that's how that's how crazy it is it's
coming it comes in it comes in waves the
best way i can explain it to people who
don't have it is i don't smoke weed i i
have done in the past but like i assume
you've you've smoked yeah um for me i
can't smoke it because i lose my head so
you know that moment when your brain
sort of floats off and you stop being
conscious you're conscious but you stop
having your you're not as alert and then
suddenly you become back to reality for
a few seconds that's what my brain does
with cancer so because i had that that
trigger when i was younger that's really
given me this kind of
disorder
so to speak and then and then that ocd
has
grown and taken so many different
tangents my granddad who's on my this
arm my best mate and my best man he'll
be my best man at my wedding he um
he got ill with septicemia when i was
like 14 and i got home and my mum had
told me that he was in the hospital and
i remember i went and saw him went home
i had a picture of him and he was
holding me when i was a baby on my wall
and i my lucky number's 13 and i kissed
it 13 times and then a couple of days
later he got better so that [ __ ]
triggered me and then and then i could
not go to sleep without kissing it 13
times i've never been a religious guy
i've actively always spoken about my
atheism probably because i was trying to
be a b-tech ricky gervais but they are
my beliefs still now or lack of and i
made up a prayer in my head and like it
i and i knew it it was like
it's it's embarrassing to say out loud
but it's like dear god please look after
my mom dad nan grandad's sister and then
i'd name them all and then i'd have to
say it three times and even though i
wasn't saying it out loud if i tripped
over a word even thinking it like i
thought of the wrong word in the wrong
order i'd have to go back and do it
again i went to have a sleepover around
my friends and then halfway through the
night realized [ __ ] i haven't kissed
that photo of my grandad so i have to go
home
like that's how how mad it is and now
luckily with the numbers and the
patterns and the sort of more
the sort of more known about aspects of
ocd if you will um the more documented
parts of it i don't necessarily have
those i obsess over time and sunsets and
sunrise which is weird but the cancer
thing is something that really
consumes my life
and if anyone if there's an advert come
on for cancer research i have to shoot
up and turn it off and it's
it's alarm bells in my head ding ding
ding yeah there's been a few times
during this this chat where my brain's
gone off and it's like
things like oh if you you need to write
a will or oh
how's what people what's gonna happen to
the channel when you die like all the
little
things yeah it's a weird it's a it's a
strange thing but i spoke about this
with joe weller on my podcast and i've
had hundreds of people dm me on
instagram saying they have a similar
thing
and although i don't reply to all of
them i try and get my way through as
many as i can
steep that yeah but you know on one hand
it was because it's it's it's not a
world i'm thankful i'm thankful it's not
a world that i that i know but i was sat
there thinking oh my god then you can't
be the only one
that's going through that and i and it's
so amazing that you're so honest about
that because it there'll be people
listening to this right now that go that
is me and i'm that the concept of health
anxiety seems so alien to me but 15
times a day you said thinking about
cancer or death or mortality and it's
not the prospect if you might have it
it's my brain telling me i do have it
there's no other outcome it'll be i'll
be chatting to you now and then it
for a minute my head will be going oh
remember you've got remember you you're
ill you're yeah oh [ __ ] right okay i
need to deal with that at some point and
then it's almost like a that that moment
when you when you're when you're high
and then you come back down and it's
it's
what the [ __ ] and then i'm back in
there's a rapper called nf who struggles
with ocd and he talks about them he puts
it into kind of like he says they're
like black balloons that he's carrying
around in his brain and every now and
then one will float away or come back
and i really resonate to that if anyone
out there has got health anxiety and and
resonate with some of the stuff that i'm
saying today i check out check out nf
he's got a few songs about health
anxiety and ocd in there it's pretty um
they're pretty good they're pretty
accurate how does someone go about um
overcoming these things or curing them
is it therapy is there is there other
resources that they can seek i have i've
never been able to do therapy in terms
of
because i know because i don't truly
know if i'm ill or not um
i can't bring myself to get walk through
the doctor's door because if he if i get
that confirmation i melt down i probably
[ __ ] do something silly i don't know
like so i don't want that confirmation
so i'm the worst person to answer that
because i would actively encourage
people to go and
if they have a worry like go and get a
lump checked out of course why would you
not or or if you have if you know you
have this health anxiety ocd whatever
mental disorder it may be i would
actively encourage people to go and talk
to someone whether that be therapy or
whatever but i can't do it so i can't
practice what i preach my friend liz she
bought me an ocd workbook and i go
through that every now and then and
answer the questions and write things
and
yeah so it's a hard one for me to answer
because i'm i wouldn't i wouldn't be
able to practice what i what i actually
preach so you're you're too fearful to
go and get a health check done yeah i
couldn't do it i couldn't do it it's
like shop shutters come down in my brain
like that because
if i go there and the doctor's like yeah
you're ill then that's the end for me
there's no recovery process that's it
and that's a mental thing i know that's
not the right thing fiona gets upset
when she hears that but i can't maybe it
will change when i have kids would you
mean that's the end for you
i can't live with knowing i'm ill
so even because i've i've put so much
time and effort into believing it myself
my little breaks now when i'm like
actually no i'm fine i'm fine if i ever
got that confirmation i would i would
shut down i would
but that's why it's a disorder that's
why it's not
right
it's weird living with living with those
thoughts is um is not an easy thing to
do have you found yourself
my business partner you know you've met
donald gregg
with him he went through a number of
struggles which he's been very open
about and he turned to alcohol as a way
to kind of like self-medicate and i
remember coming downstairs when we lived
at the mickel door if you ever came to
me yeah yeah yeah in manchester and
finding him in the early hours of the
morning just drinking with the lights
off at like 3am yeah and then thinking
like oh this guy's just a piss-head
whatever finding out years later that he
had like some severe anxiety suicidal
ideation he used to stand on the train
station he said and considered you know
jumping in front of the chain and stuff
did you ever find yourself medicating to
try and escape some of these thoughts or
realities you're living yeah i still do
it now
i still do it now i i
i will
go out and drink with my mates and it's
not a big problem now and nothing to
worry about and if it was i wouldn't be
sat here telling you about it but i
would go out and drink with my mates and
then i would come home
and carry on just drinking on my own
because the ocd the balloons fly away
and then i feel the shop shutter goes up
and i've got this release that i've not
thought about having cancer in the past
five hours
because i've i'm i'm i've let loose on
on booze and then i'll come home and
then start to sober up and don't want
that i don't want my thoughts back again
so i will sit there and i will drink
more and it will get to six in the
morning and the sun that's why i i
obsess over sunrise as well because i
because i just
yeah it's just it's just a tough one i
can't
i struggle to sleep almost every night
because that when i get in bed
i
i think about it more and that and then
when the sunrise comes up and it's a new
day and i know i have to start again
it's it's a tough one so so i i obsess
over sunrise times and i could probably
tell you within 15 minutes maybe when
the sun rises i think it's probably like
6 52 right now maybe
what's the significance of the sun
rising sorry because i panic so much at
night time and that's when the the worst
thoughts come into my brain that
i panic so much that i can't i cannot
sleep and i'm just in a circle of
thinking cancer cancer cancer and then
and then
because
it's like i know i need sleep because i
need to go and interview this person
tomorrow or present for west ham
tomorrow it's an important thing it's
important for everyone so but i have to
be on camera i can't have bags under my
eyes as well so so i see it as an egg
timer and and i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] the sun's gonna come up and then
i've not had any sleep and i've gotta go
and perform
and so i i'm checking my time i i need
to know when this when the sun's coming
up so i i obsess over that like and
another ocd thing is i always have to
turn my phone off on the 15 minutes so i
i have to look at the time say it's 4
a.m i have to see that four zero zero
for the light to turn off before i can
settle and if i miss that and it's 401
well i'm up for another 14 minutes then
because i need to see it hit 415.
yes
it's weird and i don't mean to sound
insensitive when i say that it's weird
because because i have it myself but it
is it's an unusual thing um but there
are a lot of people out there that have
a similar thing so hit me up on dms
maybe we can have a chat did you sleep
last night not really really not in
there
if there's any talk of death
in any capacity i will relate that back
to myself and obviously i lost my dog
last night so
i was just
yeah
just up thinking yeah it's weird because
i i even thought that all that all those
thoughts plagued me and like this is
like a therapy session for me like
talking about this because i've owned
fiona has heard this a hundred times and
then no one else has really heard it but
um even though those thoughts plagued me
i am really happy
i just am
so last night you find out your dogs
passed away and you
that sends you into sort of a spiral
thinking about death more broadly in
yourself
um and that keeps you up last night yeah
yeah
yeah i i i'm in a bit of a in a bit of a
routine at the moment where like i've
had like two three hours sleep
have a really busy day today
drive back to norwich and then probably
have two three hours sleep tonight two
three out until i become exhausted and
then i can just sleep all the way
through one night and it's a reset so
like i just work until i can't anymore
but the the thing you were saying about
dom drinking at like three in the
morning like
that is
that is i've been that guy i've been
that guy 150
000 times like
yeah
so i i when you said it i could i could
envision him there because i've i've
been him
the thing that you said about your
drinking pattern that i could really
relate to is with all my mates we'd like
come home after like being in manchester
whatever and
i would like drinking ark if it was a
graph goes like up and then plateaus
because i feel like we've had enough but
what you said is that you wanted to
carry on drinking because you didn't
want the sober thoughts back and that's
exactly what i used to see in domos to
look at him and thinking why does he
never want the party to stop why does he
never want anyone to go home why does he
always
it seems like once he's had one it's a
straight line upwards until he is
incapable of pouring another yeah
whereas i was i would be like i'd have
three and then tail off and then want to
be in bed by like 2 a.m right yeah
so i have mates that like you and i'm
the dom in my group
and
and i can't i could never understand the
use i can never understand how why are
you not why do you not want to carry on
like like it doesn't matter it doesn't
make sense it's such a release for me
such a break from my everyday thoughts
what like i just assume everyone's going
to be the same like you just want to go
to bed one lay there with those thoughts
like no way like let's just carry on and
see the birds come up
fiona
tell me about that you know it's it's
it's hard enough um having a partner
anyway when you're busy and you're you
know focused on building your career as
i found out but um
when you're dealing with difficult
thoughts often it can make it i guess an
exacerbating factor so it can become
more difficult
she's just the best thing that's ever
happened to me like she's just
[ __ ] incredible like she will sit
there
and listen to me until six seven in the
morning just every time just talk about
things that's regardless of if i've been
drinking or not because i've i fear this
podcast may make it sound like that's
what i do all the time it's not like i
will do that more frequently than most
people i probably have two of those
nights a month where i stay up until the
silly hours um but compared to where i
used to be it's it's it's not it's it's
fine but she will just sit there and
listen and she's not a drinker she never
drinks um
so she'll come out on a night out and
we'll just be high on life which is
brilliant and beautiful and i wish i had
a bit of that um i don't so we're very
much chalk and cheese in that respect
but she keeps me going and there was a
time in december where i'd stayed up too
late
and uh so it was now the early hours of
sunday morning and anxiety was running
through my veins and i said i'm not
gonna
go to work on monday and i was hosting
something for west ham i said i can't do
it i said i can't look people in the
eyes i said the ocd's too much i'm i'm
shaking i'm panicking i can't face it
and she said oh you will do it i said
don't force me to do it fee please i
don't want to do it she said i'm not
gonna force you she
i got up in bed and she'd uh
packed all my stuff that i needed on my
laptop and put it in the car and then
when i was ready she was like i've run
you a bath you're gonna get a bath and
then we're gonna go to london she booked
the hotel i went to hotel woke up the
next day presented for west ham
done a good job smashed it went driving
home next day i was a bit teary-eyed and
was like i need you to just push me into
things because if i hadn't have done
that i'd have just been hating myself
for ages so she's very much my rock and
uh
sounds a bit a bit cheesy in that but i
would not be
making content now if it wasn't for her
what amazing person she's [ __ ]
beautiful mate yeah she's
yeah
she's incredible
she's incredible some of the advice she
gives me and stuff it's like and when i
met her she was having bad panic attacks
and i didn't know panic attacks were a
thing i really didn't we was in covert
garden
and we and she just started shaking and
sat on the floor and i was like what's
going on here and now she and she would
she would do no public kind of if i was
doing any public event she didn't want
to be there she didn't want to be
whatever and now it's completely flipped
i've brought her into my world whether
she wanted to or not she's been a
byproduct of me for so long and now i'm
a byproduct of her and she's
she's my backbone and she's she's got
all of her anxiety seemingly under
control i'm sure she'd tell me if not
and she doesn't have panic attacks and
now i'm that guy
and she's so
yeah shout to fiona shout out to fiona
hero it's so lovely to hear you talk
with such um admiration about her as
well because guys can sometimes they
either avoid talking about their
partners or they're they're a bit too
tough to like give them the credit for
the supporting role they play but i
think the same way with my girlfriend
who's actually upstairs now who's been a
real rock for me and a real stabilizing
force and really like helped me focus on
what actually matters in life it's like
really i think with my girlfriend she's
probably i don't know if she's even
through the curtain she can hear me but
she doesn't particularly care about what
i've achieved doesn't seem to care at
all when i if i like if i make if i made
loads of money it's more about the other
things
like in terms of being connected to my
family and being a good human being yeah
those are the kind of things she drives
me on but um fees the same yeah
yeah like me and my my family if i go
around my nan's on christmas day we're
all like we get like i love my family of
course i do but we'll watch tv like
christmas specials whatever we'll go
around fiona's house her family never
turn the tv on for the for three or four
days over the christmas period they sit
there and they talk and they love each
other and they embrace each other and
for me it's i'm like this is weird like
this is old-fashioned like
old-school values yeah but the she like
she just she's she's just so full of
love and
she just yeah she just brings everyone
closer she
she walks into a room she brightens it
so you want to be a dad someday
jeez yeah i do why was that question
difficult i don't know i don't i'm i'm i
we me and fear spoken about a lot i'm 29
now soon in two weeks so i'm getting
i feel like i have to
kind of soon um you have to kind of soon
yeah i have to have a kid soon surely
like i don't
i don't want to be what this i don't
want to be a dad that's like
60 when they're like 20. so like i don't
want to be
i don't i can't have a kid when i'm 40.
do you want to have a kid yeah i do want
to have a kid i'd be a great i'd be a
great dad
but ideally not soon
yeah i said when i was
early 20s i said by the time i'm 25
and then when i was 25 i said by the
time i'm 27
and then now i'm saying by the time i'm
30
but i've got just under 13 months so i
don't think that's gonna happen and
fiona's just had a um her sister's just
had a baby so fiona's just become a
nanny and we love the little baby of
course we do but
hard work and i can give it back when
i'm done
it doesn't feel a bit scary for a lot of
people it's quite a scary prospect for
me it's a little bit of a scary prospect
too because i think what am i going to
have to sacrifice to
i don't want to sacrifice anything
to sacrifice something to find time
right and sure
when you're very career driven yes yeah
i just sort of
run about from place to place
talking to people on a camera like
i could have a kid and fee could stay at
home and edit but
i love my life so much i don't want it
to change right now
you can have a kid i hope so i hope so
like looking through the curtain
you know you're talented right though
jack you know what your talent is right
yeah what do you think is talent is
it's a difficult question to ask people
because it makes them feel uncomfortable
but what you if you had to say like the
reason i am sat here today and the root
cause of my success what would you
diagnose if you were talking about jack
mate from like a third party perspective
i think i can speak to most people on
their level so you can put me next to
um ksi you can put me next to deborah
meaden and i'll be able to get a laugh
out of them and when they know the real
me and i'm not trying to be jackmate i
think that's a good i think that's a
good person
and i've never been the best youtuber
that's probably why i don't do the
typical youtube anymore i'm not the best
presenter
but i'm one of the best podcasters i
would say and i've found
what it is i love and what it is i'm
good at so i would say i'm a really good
talker
i would completely agree i think you're
much more talented than you give
yourself credit for actually i look at
some of the stuff you do specifically
with presenting actually and podcasting
but presenting and podcasting and it's
clearly
almost a bit like will brazil like
clearly a real talent that is in my view
like impossible to replicate
like i like and you talked about
potentially in the future doing some
stand-up stuff i saw you talking about
that before mm-hmm
you'd be great at that i could never do
like i don't believe i could have i
shouldn't be such a pessimistic person
you've been doing big theater
productions right now they're making
people i'm not trying to make people
laugh i'm trying to make them cry it's
like it's like a completely yeah but
that's a fine line in comedy if you can
make it if you can make someone cry you
can make someone laugh it's all about
emotions
that's what it's all about do you know
what it is it's like the labels we give
ourselves and i've never labeled myself
as like a funny person i've never told
myself that i could make people laugh
whereas you do that you do that very
almost like effortlessly and i think to
be honest i think you've been practicing
since you're a kid as you've said so
i did um
i did two shows um opening up for max
fosh in november
and they were the best moments ever of
your life yeah and that was stand up
yeah
yeah i feel a bit silly saying it
because max fosh did an hour a
beautiful show um
and it was called social butterfly um it
was spelled with zed for for a reason
that becomes clear in the show but he
had um presentations and everything and
he came on my podcast i said oh you're a
real stand-up now you've just done a
tour all up and down and kind of he was
like no i don't feel like a stand-up
because i had these aids and it was
almost just whatever and i was then i
felt like an idiot because i'd just done
five minutes opening up for him and i
was putting online that i've just done
my dream i've but i had i had i was i
was i was so nervous i i pretty much had
a panic attack before i went out i was
looking at figa and i can't do it
shaking couldn't do it couldn't do it
had all my little jokes written on my
hand there but they already had already
sweated off and i tell you what steve
like i put myself down a lot and we've
spoken about self-deprecating humor i
went out on stage max fosh just suddenly
went ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
stage chat man i went out
and that was what i was meant to be
doing like i everything any comedian
that told me on my podcast came to me in
that moment and i learned that and
applied it on the stage and i had people
eating at the palm of my hand and i
would make a joke and i would but when i
did a bit of stand up years ago i rushed
through it
because i wanted it to be over i was in
the moment and i was able to live in the
moment and leave pauses and hit beats
and it was well good i walked out and
the guy in
in the front row had my merch on so yeah
there's one guy here that knows so i was
able to talk to him you want to do that
more yeah i will do it now now i know i
can do it i will do it there's surely
there's no feeling like that like in
front of people live and they're just
you know hearing that laugh is
i've never done heroin but i imagine
that's what it's like to do to get that
hit
and i want that i want that back that
was like the biggest rush that i've felt
in in a long time and you are you
thinking about doing that as a hap under
the happy hour brand i think i'll do a
happy hour show um whatever that may be
but then i also want to do a
jack dean or jack mate stand-up show um
i've got loads and loads of stand-up
bits written down i've i've got notepads
and
macbooks full of full of jokes so
there's nothing like it there's nothing
like the real world
we get kind of lost in the digital world
there's like content creators or
whatever but last night and the last few
nights at the palladium have been the
most
like uh nothing has made me feel as
alive as that so
anyway israel
i should know i don't normally say this
but [ __ ] it you know israel was here
yesterday so you know it's called the
questions from him usually we don't tell
people who the question is from right
but israel adasanya
wrote a question for you
this is the this is the goat of fighting
right this is the goat right yeah he
wrote a question for you
hero
and you've got to answer this with total
honesty that's the only rule here you've
got to answer it with detail
he said
how are you truly
feeling
content
i was gonna say happy
but i still have some issues i need to
iron out
so i'm content
and i feel privileged to be where i am
that's what i'll say
you probably wanted a better answer but
there we go so are you getting perfect
thank you so much thank you thank you
for your time and i'm so glad we finally
got to do this because you've been an
inspiration for me i think essentially
because of your willingness to be so
open and honest with things and i don't
think you'll ever see the impact that
that openness has on thousands hundreds
of thousands and millions of people it's
like i think more people need to do need
to find within themselves to do that
because as you've said today it's
liberating for you like the therapy of
just being able to say it kind of lifts
the weight but it also lifts the weight
for everybody listening and so i applaud
you for that and your self-awareness
about the journey you've come on as a
creator as a man in your maturity so
thank you it's a pleasure to sit here
and thank you for the inspiration no
thank you mate it means a lot and thank
you for having me on the show it's a
great show so um yeah let's do mine and
we'll speak about your favorite let's go
do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]